buonasera sono molto contento che questa
presentazione si tenga subito dopo il
break perché non sarà così tranquilla e
divertente e leggera come leggera nel
senso migliore
di molte delle altre che abbiamo
ascoltato sono un sociologo studio la
cittadinanza presiede un think thank
europeo che si occupa di cittadinanza si
chiama fondata non sono un euro e
entusiasta non sono nemmeno un euro
scettico sono un europeo anzi sono
romano italiano ed europeo come è giusto
che sia però non mi dimentico mai che
c'è un sacco di gente nel mondo che
rischia di morire per venire a vivere in
un posto che magari noi riteniamo essere
il peggiore e che invece è uno dei
migliori luoghi e ci sia per vivere
rocks of life e io comincio parlando di
fiumi l'europa ha molti fiumi alcuni di
questi ci dicono delle delle notizie
la marna il reno l'isonzo il volga e
molti altri fiumi fiumi che attraversano
l'europa in cui si è soprattutto
combattuto il prossimo anno nel 2014
sarà il centenario dell'inizio della
prima guerra mondiale
sapete ci sono state due guerre mondiali
nel ventesimo del ventesimo secolo e qui
a un po di numeri il primo secondo me
non si riesce a concepire 80 milioni di
morti soprattutto civili nelle due
guerre mondiali del novecento 300.000 è
il numero che uno stato un stato
maggiore di uno degli eserciti della
prima guerra mondiale prevedeva di
numero di soldati che prevedeva che
morissero in un'offensiva che stavano
progettando 5000 è il numero medio di
morti che ogni giorno per cinque anni ci
sono stati per i cinque anni della prima
guerra mondiale dal 14 al 18 60.000 uno
stadio di calcio è il numero dei soldati
morti
in un solo attacco di una sola offensiva
di un solo giorno in un solo posto il
posto e questo è la somma è questo e
l'esercito britannico
da qui la espressione inglese john
glover the top
quello che mi ha sempre stupito il
colpito della prima guerra mondiale che
non erano le armi a essere un
prolungamento dei combattenti ma i
combattenti a essere un prolungamento
delle armi potevano essere appunto
calcolati in centinaia di migliaia come
morti potevano essere sacrificati in
attacchi suicidi per guadagnare poche
centinaia di metri come in questa
battaglia della della somma e questo era
ritenuto del tutto normale c'era poi un
altra caratteristica vivere nelle
trincee a pochi metri dal dal nemico
spesso visto il tempo vivendo in una
fanghiglia che era un po fatta di terra
un po fatta di corpi in decomposizione i
fatti chi c'era dice che tutto si può
raccontare della prima guerra mondiale
ma non l'odore che si viveva nelle
trincee si era assediati dai pidocchi
i topi spuntavano dai corpi in
decomposizione questo per anni e anni in
certe trincee come quelle delle montagne
tra l'italia e l'austria si moriva più
di malattie di freddo che non per il
nemico dobbiamo ricordarci di queste
cose quando parliamo dell'europa se no
non ci spieghiamo perché sia nata è nata
dalle macerie di queste due guerre e
anche quando diciamo ma l'europa è un
mercato
ricordiamo che nacque come mercato per
mettere in comune le due principali
materie prime con cui si fa la guerra il
carbone e l'acciaio
1956 e questo è il senso fondamentale
dell'unione europea evitare che succeda
di nuovo qualcosa come le due guerre
mondiali
mai più eventi come quelli mai più il
nazionalismo che se non è stato la causa
è stato il fattore scatenante di tutte e
due le guerre mondiali l'idea che sia
comunque una ottima idea per qualunque
ragione morire per la patria andare
volontari in guerra e distruggere altre
nazioni
la identità degli europei è per fortuna
all identità costruita per evitare che
di nuovo prevalga il nazionalismo per
quante difficoltà possiamo avere oggi ci
sono alcuni addetti ai lavori
dell'europa che in ottima fede si sono
dispiaciuti per il fatto che gli europei
non si sentono non si emozionano per
l'europa per esempio non si commuovono
sentendo l'inno alla gioia che l'inno
dell'unione europea o guardando la
bandiera a dodici stelle o anche
guardando le banconote della moneta
unica è certo dipende dalle banconote
naturalmente ma poi questi non le avete
mai viste nel che non siete
narcotrafficanti e
l'identità europea non è fatta per
commuoversi ha un'identità a bassa
intensità
per fortuna dovremmo essere orgogliosi è
un'identità un grande filosofo diceva ma
l'abbiamo delle somiglianze di famiglia
in una famiglia si riconosce che si è di
con la stessa famiglia perché ci sono
dei particolari il naso il colore degli
occhi il colore dei capelli ma è
difficile dire che cosa ci tiene insieme
ci tiene insieme la diversità è un po
paradossale l'identità europea ciò che
ci accomuna è la diversità e poi dopo le
due guerre mondiali
abbiamo fatto una specie di
assicurazione contro noi stessi contro
il rischio che si potessero ripetere
queste cose e abbiamo inventato
contribuito all'affermazione in tutto il
mondo dei diritti umani con la
dichiarazione delle nazioni unite nel 48
ora questi diritti sono parte della
costituzione europea e vi ricordo che
c'è un tribunale penale internazionale
che giudica i crimini contro l'umanità
in base a questi diritti
per noi è come dire non siamo diventati
più buoni ma abbiamo imparato a
difenderci da noi stessi vent'anni fa
giusto vent'anni fa è stata istituita la
cittadinanza dell'unione europea persone
fisicamente visibile nei passaporti che
sono tutti uguali hanno lo stesso colore
hanno tutti iscritto unione europea
prima del nome dello stato fu istituita
proprio per creare un contrappeso
rispetto al possibili rischi di
economicismo e di tecnocrazia della
dell'unione europea non ha non ha mai
avuto una grande stampa diciamo la
cittadinanza europea per alcuni era solo
una scatola vuota un oggetto di
comunicazione pubblica per altri era una
minaccia alla sovranità nazionale dei
paesi membri dell'unione
ma cerchiamo di capire meglio che cosa
c'era dentro nel trattato di vent'anni
fa si dice e cittadino dell'unione
chiunque sia cittadino di uno degli
stati membri e stabilirà una serie di
diritti la libera circolazione
la non discriminazione sulla base della
nazionalità
il diritto di candidarsi e votare per il
parlamento europeo e per le elezioni
amministrative della città in cui si
vive qualunque essa sia il diritto di
fare petizioni e reclami alle
istituzioni europee nella propria lingua
l'europ l'unione europea 23 lingue
ufficiali uno che ne manca il diritto
alla tutela diplomatica è poco guardiamo
meglio ci sono due aspetti che vorrei
farvi notare il primo sono le anomalie
di questa cittadinanza europea rispetto
alle altre cittadinanze la cittadinanza
europea è l'unica cittadinanza moderna
che non nasca dall'autorità di uno stato
nazionale come ho detto unisce popoli
individui che hanno poco di positivo in
comune i diritti che vi ho fatto vedere
prima non hanno nessun senso della
dimensione nazionale
per esempio il diritto della libera
circolazione e si nasconde nelle pieghe
di quei diritti nel diritto di votare
per le elezioni amministrative della
città in cui si risiede un principio su
cui si basa la cittadinanza che non è né
quello dello ius soli e quello dello ius
sanguinis di cui si parla dopo un po
sconclusionato in italia ma che il
principio di residenza si hanno dei
diritti di cittadinanza in quanto si
risiede in un posto lo ius domicili lo
chiamano la partecipazione politica non
riguarda solo il voto ma anche la
partecipazione alla formazione alla
messa in opera delle politiche pubbliche
europee queste anomalie sono
interessanti perché tutte le
cittadinanze nel mondo stanno vivendo
questi problemi
molte identità confini incerti scarsa
efficacia del voto diritti che
riguardano posizioni che vanno oltre le
responsabilità i poteri degli stati da
questo punto di vista quello che noi con
difficoltà sperimentiamo è utile e
importante per tutti è il secondo punto
che mi ha sempre colpito della
cittadinanza europea e che se la
guardiamo non corrono status giuridico
ma come un processo in cui non sono solo
le istituzioni a fare le cose ma anche i
cittadini
vediamo che ha una capacità di evolversi
di arricchirsi di estendersi qui ci sono
quattro esempi diritti di welfare
stabiliti solo per i lavoratori che
andavano a lavorare in un altro dei
paesi dell'unione estesi a tutti i
soggetti tutti i cittadini europei
compresi quelli che non possono lavorare
come disabili gravi
i diritti dei pazienti tradizionalmente
una competenza esclusiva degli stati
nazionali ma che grazie al movimento
civico europeo sono stati assunti come
responsabilità europea dall'unione si
sono trasformati in un sistema di
standard per il modo di trattare i
cittadini malati che deve essere
assicurato in tutta europa il il diritto
di iniziativa legislativa un milione di
cittadini europei possono proporre le
istituzioni dell'unione e una nuova
legge raccogliendo le firme anche online
in questo momento ci sono 17 proposte di
legge per esempio riguardano l'acqua
tanto per dirne una l'acqua come bene
comune
in questo momento si stanno raccogliendo
le firme per 17 proposte infine una
proposta che non ha avuto esito ma
importante che sia stata formulata
quella proprio sulla base del principio
di non discriminazione che citavo prima
di riconoscere la cittadinanza
dell'unione europea anche in assenza
della cittadinanza nazionale a tutti gli
immigrati legali che dicevano da almeno
cinque anni nel territorio dell'unione
europea non è stata approvata ma è stata
formulata e da questo punto di vista il
principio di non discriminazione è molto
importante
va tutto bene no no perché la gestione
della crisi dell'eurozona è fatta molto
di tecnocrazia economicismo in un gioco
a somma zero in cui qualcuno deve
vincere e qualcuno
i cittadini devono perdere perché c'è
una crescente sfiducia che si
manifesterà probabilmente nelle prossime
elezioni europee dove tutti temono che
succederà qualcosa come quello che è
successo in italia lo scorso anno giusto
perché voi lo sappiate e soprattutto dal
mio punto di vista più terra terra il
contenuto della cittadinanza europea non
è affatto chiaro nemmeno ai dirigenti
dell'unione europea
gli esempi che ho fatto prima non li
ritrovereste in un elenco di
caratteristiche e contenuti della
cittadinanza europea
il mio punto quindi è questo trovereste
solo quello che è scritto nei trattati
cioè nella costituzione il mio punto
quindi e questo è molto semplice e
chiudo con questo a luglio da luglio a
dicembre
l'italia avrà il suo semestre di
presidenza dell'unione europea che è una
cosa che viene fatta a turno dai paesi
membri
come vedete da questa slide di solito
questi semestri sono un'ottima occasione
di esercizio per i grafici e anche si
tengono molti eventi ad alta rilevanza
mediatica di cui tutti si scordano il
giorno dopo che è finito il semestre
io dico almeno una cosa utile che resti
nel tempo facciamo la facciamo in codice
scriviamo in codice della cittadinanza
europea in cui per la prima volta visto
che nessuno sa qual è il suo contenuto
effettivo che si nasconde in sentenze
della corte di giustizia in politiche
pubbliche in effetti dell'azione dei
movimenti di cittadini e così via
siano elencati chiaramente per tutti noi
diritti doveri poteri responsabilità dei
cittadini
comunitari ma anche dei cittadini non
comunitari che vivono nel territorio
dell'unione
questo penso che sarebbe ricordato e per
una volta noi italiani saremo forse
anche ricordati più a lungo e meglio in
europa grazie